and praxis is clearly [ __ ] awesome
swag aside like this level of almost
like celebrity appeal right is really
good but his play style is really you
need not many people play like him he
can do everything
even though right yes it's really easy
to play with him and he's a really good
player he's always been good right let
me get one extra swag swag with three
frags
finally make a look at what's been taken
away from them like it's the the no pro
core no pro career is even possible no
involvement in counter-strike cool on
anything that involves valve and then
swag obviously [ __ ] probably the best
player in na it's just really
unfortunate it's such a shitty situation
because it's like there's two sides
every story obviously you know what I
mean so for me it'll be too harsh for
what happened for me the first time it
ever happened
understand the consequences understand
ho-oh Hardy was compulsory braxton swag
Pierce was once one of North American
counter strikes the fastest rising stars
now he's on the sidelines but before he
was permanently banned from valve events
swag was considered by some to be the
next great na player and there were
plenty of indications that it might
happen
born in North Carolina in 1996 swag was
seven years old when he played Counter
Strike for the first time initially
trying the game at his cousin's house
his obsession with the game was not
immediate like so many players though he
was eventually sucked in by CS 1.6 in
his early teens he became a strong
enough player to begin playing in ESEA
and would make his land debut with full
gaming in season 9 at the age of 15 they
drove like 14 hours in North Carolina to
support him and it was his mom is like
aunt and his older brother and they it
all came there I was like your swag
right and I shook his hand I shake
everyone's hand the thing and I was like
hey do not I look forward to playing
against you and he was like literally
tiny of this one it was so awesome he
would move on to join back-to-back
gaming where he would play it with sean
gares and eventually sent this competing
in the ESEA season 10 invite land swags
early success was enough to attract
attention on its own but it was his
signature style of play which emphasized
patience and lurking that marked him as
something truly special I definitely had
respect for because I had watch them
online and normally when you watched
up-and-coming kids they're very like
hyper aggressive and their aim and
dexterity is just so amazing right but
it wasn't only that the kid was super
patient and just like out playing kids
and I was like oh he's actually like got
patience a swagger is a little different
he was like kind of you'd mess with me
jiggle peek me wait they do these little
things you need to his teammates become
a little Bader but he would always like
seal the deal for his team and I've
never watched him just feel like oh and
not only that the kids actually a good
kid he's like he's communicating well he
doesn't really [ __ ] to his teammates
like when he dies he's just kind of like
having fun and I was a loudest awesome
it was when swag joined team dynamic in
September 2012 that his potential
started to become known in the North
American scene playing on a roster with
a dren and AZK the team came second at
the ESEA invites season 12 Global Finals
losing to area 51 gaming it's all up now
to swag can you save the day no 51 is
your invite champion here for the first
csgo invite land for ESC
but then like I'm pretty sure wasn't
after long till 1.6 was having a little
decline and there wasn't as many good
players in North America I was like this
kids got to be on my team there's no
question about it
and we started playing on each other's
team and then I think we won the last
couple like 1.6 LANs together and then
of course going into go he's just kind
of a natural it was also the competitive
ESEA LAN debut of Counter Strike global
Offensive after its release on August
21st 2012 swag continued his ascent
through the competitive scene though
they added nothing to the roster in
November 2012 team dynamic broke up in
late February 2013 swag and nothing
stuck together in a roster called
lurking and working which brought back
sean gares
and symphysis adding hiko to the mix
after five months the roster was
transferred to complexity gaming at the
ESEA season 14 land the team came up
short in the grand finals against ninjas
in pyjamas who had been on a tear since
the release of global Offensive you're
talking [ __ ] about nip but the
complexity roster has shown that the
assembled skill of symphysis
nothing sean gares hiko and swag or a
dangerous force in late 2013 the team
managed a 3rd to 4th finish against
eventual tournament winners fnatic at
Dreamhack winter 2013 while complexity
continued to be competitive they fell
short against both European mainstays in
csgo in early 2014
swag took the next step in his career
making it known that he wanted to leave
complexity which he eventually did to
join iBUYPOWER
it was with ibuypower where he would
rejoin AZK also already on the roster
were in-game leader days and opted
prodigy skadoodle days later they added
steel as their 5th immediately the
roster looked like they could become a
dominant force in CS goes north
scene but the big break for iBUYPOWER
was at the ESA season 16 land finals
they're playing complexity gaming in the
grand finals iBUYPOWER showed that a
shift really was taking place in NACS
facing down four former teammates swag
was a crucial part of his team's success
after he'd going back seven and that is
going to do it your ESEA season 16 land
final champions is going to be iBUYPOWER
the team continue to gather momentum
they earned a trip to ESL one cologne
where they earn valuable experience
against fnatic and virtus pro in Group C
they demolished cloud nine at the SIBO
season five professional finals for one
two months later 1917 in overtime they
are grand final champions first ever see
the land and there's the team cam as you
see them hugging it out they are so
happy about that publicly everything
seemed to be growing well they and not
cloud nine made it out of the group
stage at the face of League season to
land finals taking a game from fnatic in
the grand finals like dominoes and
iBUYPOWER they they win that round in
like 20 seconds that was a thousand full
bite fnatic not able to even put the
slice of ice into that last round in
early January the roster left iBUYPOWER
and founded GX swag going along with
them Steele had already left the team
and had been replaced by hiko rumors
swirled that the team would be picked up
by none other than Evil Geniuses
who had left the counter-strike scene
and early
thousand twelve but the team had already
made a fateful choice one that would
change the course of the players careers
and perhaps North American
counter-strike as a whole
it was August 20th 2014 during steve-o
season 5 when the team lost a game
against netcode guides calm a 16-2 for
trouncing on de seasons off they know
where he is now makes a shot and Tariq
shuts it down netcode guides beating
iBUYPOWER
on season natkho guides was a team that
iBUYPOWER
would normally have been expected to
easily beat while there were immediate
concerns from fans that a game appear to
have been thrown complaints that tend to
surface whenever an upset happens they
initially appeared to be baseless
however eSports journalist Richard Lewis
uncovered some evidence almost
immediately that suggested that the
match had been fixed a conflict of
interest between Dazed & netcode guides
was exposed and it was revealed that
Dazed co-owned the group that owned
netcode guides chat messages showed
Shazam then a content creator for that
group confirming the match had been
fixed
he later offered a no comment the story
dropped off the map until January 2015
when Lewis published a follow-up reports
it referenced a series of text messages
sent by Derek Bourne telling his
ex-girlfriend that not only had the
match been fixed he had placed bets for
the iBUYPOWER roster on alternate
accounts through former competitive
player duct cut fan once Lewis presented
this and other evidence to csgo lounge
they confirmed the transactions on
alternate accounts had been placed by
fan what is he doing why did he hesitate
Shazam also confirmed to Lewis that the
match-fixing had taken place 11 days
later valve issue the notorious
integrity and Fairplay blog post that
banned fam Bourne Necco guides founder
Casey foster along with Dazed swag AZK
and steal from official valve events
skadoodle was the only member of the
roster to not be banned given that Valve
had access to the information about the
skins being transferred it is presumed
he did
not benefits something steal confirmed
in a statement after the bans were
announced in the end for promising
players lost their entire careers that
day all for a handful of skins the exact
amount of which is in dispute but which
days claimed was around $700 per player
people's people's careers have just been
ended today by Volvo gaben gayben has
come down and struck multiple people he
hurts my back cover swag joined cloud9
as an analyst and streamer he could not
compete at valve sponsored events and
whether or not tournament organizers
would let him compete at third-party
tournaments was sometimes unclear nearly
a year later valve issued a statement
that clarified the bans our decision was
to ban these players indefinitely from
involvement in valve sponsored events to
clarify the bans for these players are
permanent and players proven to have
taken part in match fixing will be
permanently banned during the ban a swag
continued to stream and as so often
happens his legend only grew the
mystique of the banned player is a
recurring theme in eSports but nowhere
is this felt so strongly as with swag
who has arguably not yet even hit his
prime
swag and his teammates did eventually
receive some good news
both ESL and Dreamhack confirmed that
they will allow the X I buy power
members to compete at their events
provided they are not valve sponsored
while swag has played in online leagues
like ESEA during his ban he also played
for cloud9
at the csgo summit where he again showed
that the once-upon-a-time NACS prodigy
has still got it oh shut up swag get the
B phase but but really knowing that swag
may still be that same player who showed
up to his first event at 15 years old
doesn't make the band easier to bear in
many ways the story of swag could still
end up being very different from the
plot so far and many fans have adapted
the hashtag free swag and free Brax in
support of unbanning swag from valve
sponsored events these fans hope that
his story is simply a prologue for
something greater to come and that swags
punishment will eventually fit the crime
that the fallen hero will one day get
his shot at redemption
[Music]
you